- In the first volume of his 2002 memoir,
"Living to Tell the Tale"
or "Vivir para Contarla",
Colombian author and Nobel Prize
in Literature winner
Gabriel García Márquez
wrote: "Life is not what one lived,
but rather what one remembers,
and how it is remembered
to tell the tale."
And while Marquez was
specifically referring
to the nature of autobiography,
it is hard not to hear his words
and specifically relate to
them the sub-genre of fiction
that he helped spearhead, magical realism.
(upbeat bright music)
Broadly speaking, magical realism
is a literary fiction style
that paints a realistic view
of the contemporary world,
while also adding magical elements,
blurring the lines between
fantasy and reality.
While the label itself
is kind of nebulous,
professor of English,
Wendy Faris, mapped out several tenets
that she believes are the
building blocks to the genre.
And as luck would have it,
everybody's favorite fictional author,
Jimmy Squibbles, is working
on his magical realist sequel
to his first novel,
"Hype House Bloodbath".
TENET NUMBER ONE:
An "irreducible" magic
which cannot be explained
by typical notions of natural law.
In this case, Jimmy
Squibbles wakes up one day
to realize he has been
turned into a horse.
TENET NUMBER TWO:
A realist description
that stresses normal,
common, every-day phenomena,
which is then revised or
"refelt" by the marvelous.
Extreme or amplified
states of mind or setting
are often used to accomplish this.
This distinguishes the
genre from myth or fantasy.
In this case, Jimmy's Hype
House roommates, Chad and Kyle,
do not seem to mind that
Jimmy is now a horse,
continuing to film their
15-million follower vlogs
without his human presence,
and no one in the comments
seems to notice his absence either.
Jimmy lives his life as best
as he can in horse form,
but finds challenges in trying
to go lifting at the gym
and meeting girls at the club.
TENET NUMBER THREE:
The novel causes the reader to be drawn
between the two views of reality.
The reader is meant to question
if Jimmy is better off as a horse,
freed from the constraints of celebrity,
or if he should find the
solution to turn himself back
into a YouTube superstar.
TENET NUMBER FOUR:
These two visions or realms
nearly merge or intersect.
Jimmy the horse begins to see
the value in equine freedom
after romping the fields
with his fellow horses.
His YouTube audience finally
discovers his secret.
TENET NUMBER FIVE:
Time is both history and the timeless;
space is often challenged;
identity is broken down at times.
Jimmy decides he IS the horse.
He opens a Hype House stable
for his new equine friends.
Historically, the term
was coined as a comment
upon the emergence of a
certain kind of realism
in the visual arts.
It was first used in 1925 by art critic
Franz Roh to define art that
contrasted with realism,
that included elements
identifiable as "real",
but were mixed with aspects
of the uncanny or fantastic
to the point where one
questions the "real".
From Gustave Courbet's
realist masterpiece,
A Burial At Ornans, wherein
everything from subject matter,
form and presentation
are near photographic
in how close to reality
they are, to something like
Rene Magritte's The Son of Man,
which juxtaposes objects
pulled from real life
in a manner that heightens
them to fantasy and mystery.
And, once again, we are
working in loose terms here.
As a literary movement,
however, magical realism's roots
are fairly global.
Loosely, it began in Europe,
in the 1910s-1920s, with works like
Franz Kafka's
"The Metamorphosis",
in which its workhorse
salesman, Gregor Samsa,
is turned into a giant bug
within the novella's very first sentence,
and has to confront the reality
of his otherwise ordinary
life as a massive bug;
and more than 100 years later,
it is still relatable
as a surreal commentary
on the grind of existence.
But the major turning
point was Roh's writings
on art being translated into Spanish
with the assistance of major Spanish
philosopher and essayist,
José Ortega y Gasset.
And from there, as Latin
American writers were traveling
between their home countries
and European cultural hubs,
authors began cheerleading
the genre and publishing works
that formed the basis of the
genre across the continent,
like Jorge Luis Borges' 1935
"A Universal History of Infamy"
and Alejo Carpentier's
"The Kingdom of This World".
In the 1960s, however, magical realism
finally came to the
forefront of world literature
with Latin America's
Boom Period of writing,
where authors like Gabriel García Márquez
first came to international prominence
with perhaps the most famous
magical realist novel,
his 1967 opus "One Hundred
Years of Solitude".
Written by Márquez in 1967
translated into 46 languages
with over 57 million copies sold,
"One Hundred Years of Solitude"
tells the multi-generational
story of the Buendía family,
whose patriarch, José Arcadio Buendía,
founded the fictional Colombian town
of Macondo after having
seen it in a dream.
The narrative follows roughly
seven generations of
the family in Macondo,
from their origins in an
isolated, primitive village,
to civil war, to striking,
to state-sponsored massacres,
to ultimately ending up a ghost
town wiped from existence.
Suffice to say, it's A LOT.
While this is far from
Márquez's only dalliance
into magical realism, like
"Love in the Time of Cholera",
it's his most notable.
But its intensity and bold embracing
of both the supernatural
and the historical
struck audiences immediately.
Said author Toni Morrison
upon reading "One Hundred
Years" for the first time,
"There was something so
familiar about the novel,
so recognizable to me.
It was a certain kind of
freedom, a structural freedom,
a different notion of a
beginning, middle, and end.
Culturally, I felt intimate with him
because he was happy to mix
the living and the dead.
His characters were on intimate terms
with the supernatural world,
and that's the way stories
were told in my house."
Author Pablo Neruda referred to it
as "The greatest revelation
in the Spanish language
since Don Quixote of Cervantes".
So what makes it magical realism?
Besides, you know, it being
about a town discovered
through dreams and people
flying up into the sky?
It's not just the emphasis on dreams,
but on the mixing of real aspects
of Colombian culture and history,
with Márquez alluding to
or directly folding in
events like the Thousand Days'
War and the Banana Massacre.
Then there are the
"impossible" things happening.
the last surviving Buendía's son,
a product of unknowing incest,
being born with a tail
or, more infamously,
Remedios Buendía, the
beauty of the family,
rising up into heaven one
day while folding laundry.
Said Yale Professor Emeritus of Hispanic
and Comparative Literature
Roberto González Echevarría,
"In 'One Hundred Years of Solitude'
myth and history overlap.
The myth acts as a vehicle
to transmit history to the reader.
García Márquez's novel can furthermore
be referred to as anthropology,
where truth is found in language and myth.
What is real and what is
fiction are indistinguishable."
The Buendías' lives and magical exploits
are so entwined with
the history of Colombia
and the very land itself,
that the fantastical
and real blend together
into one liminal space,
where the false heightens the
drama and pain of real life
into the magical, and real life becomes
a place to ground the mysteries
of things inexplicable.
Said Author Salman Rushdie
in his 2014 New York Times
obituary for Márquez,
"We live in an age of
invented, alternate worlds.
Tolkien's Middle-earth,
Rowling's Hogwarts,
the dystopic universe
of 'The Hunger Games',
the places where vampires
and zombies prowl:
These places are having their day.
Yet in spite of the vogue
for fantasy fiction,
in the finest of literature's
fictional microcosms
there is more truth than fantasy.
In the Macondo of Gabriel García Márquez,
imagination is used to enrich reality,
not to escape from it."
To this day, the genre
continues to be the source
of some of contemporary
literature's most popular authors,
like Isabel Allende, Toni
Morrison, and Salman Rushdie.
While magical realism is a
movement that spans continents,
it is most often associated
with Latin America.
Some writers have argued
the uniqueness of Latin American history
has played a critical role
in defining the genre,
with Alejo Carpentier arguing in his essay
"On the Marvelous Real in America":
"Because of the virginity of the land,
our upbringing, our ontology,
the Faustian presence of the
Indian and the Black man,
the revelation constituted
by its recent discovery,
its fecund racial mixing,
America is far from using up
its wealth of mythologies.
After all, what is the
entire history of America
if not a chronicle of
the marvellous real?"
Magical realism as a genre has been used
to reflect the hard,
ugly truth of real life,
but it is also been used
to find the extraordinary
in the small moments,
and these enduring qualities
have made their home
in a new generation of writers,
from examples like Silvia
Moreno-Garcia's "Signal to Noise"
and Ta-Nehisi Coates' "The Water Dancer",
to Zoraida Córdova's "The
Inheritance of Orquídea Divina".
This is to say nothing of
magical realism's impacts
on other forms of media,
in particular, filmmaking.
From "Amélie" to "Pan's Labyrinth",
to Disney's newest
animated feature "Encanto",
which openly is a love-letter to Márquez
and Latin American authors
of the genre itself,
magical realism is not going anywhere
and that is why it is important
to not just honor the genre,
but the people it comes from
and the reality of
which they are speaking.
So to end with another Rushdie quote,
"When people use the term magic realism,
usually they only mean 'magic'
and they don't hear 'realism',
whereas the way in which
magic realism actually works
is for the magic to be rooted in the real.
It's both things.
It's not just a fairytale moment,
it's the surrealism that
arises out of the real."